lt ragazzi e per meriti questo e un
video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo su un
videogame po diverso dal solito perché
in genere questo è un videogame che si
fa il live streaming di gioco con i miei
amici ogni tanto e quindi l'ultima volta
che ci ho giocato ho deciso di farci
anche un video ma la come esperimento
per vedere come viene visto che era un
cazzeggio puro italia questo gioco va
giocato seriamente invece noi abbiamo
fatto il cazzo anni tanto per cambiare
partiamo colpito bella league ci vediamo
dopo le altre ragazze benvenuto che sono
video sarò fa vj ventoux dei siamo su h1
z1 che un certo che non ho mai fatto
nella mia vita
noi rotta ci ho giocato però non l'ho
mai registrato e sono con questi uomini
belli presentatevi in modo molto
intelligente sono quello bello
dell'altra volta
beh io sono un cavallo pensate io gioco
questa gente nel tempo libero
io scelgo questa questa nera che si
chiama antonia antonia cioè il punto
esclamativo non va bene il nome antonio
allora chiamiamo c vene duro secono me
questa è questo va bene
antonia no per open e duro sia in realtà
in questa questa zona dove siamo adesso
è una zona che caso serve a niente non
ho mai capitata sedute che per far
capire per far casino a ok va bene all
intervallo si parte tra tipo un minuto e
quando partiamo partiamo tutti quanti
siamo tipo in 120 più o meno si parte il
ti buttano col paracadute in una mappa
grossa una grossa e rimette vince chi
sopravvive rimane per ultimo c'è
veramente quando ci buttano dobbiamo
trovare armi cose per sopravvivere e ci
dobbiamo ammazzare a vicenda ovviamente
noi facciamo squadra quelli con le
frecce intendo per questo pensa che che
cazzo di squadra ciò che c'è un idiota
su una caso fine eccomi anch'io sto
facendo il segno di farvi di venire
perché siamo amici e poi c'è anche
questo è un segno di amicizia grazie al
regalo questo binocolo ho trovato ogni
scontro al carrefour pardo lo vediamo
che su quei pantaloni dell'attacco dei
giganti
proprio perché c'è luca che picchia i
giganti bravo noi andiamo ragazzi da
ovest sud ovest dove cadiamo che
dobbiamo cadere insieme su una bici
perché nord nord est sotto nord est le
roulotte
io vado giù nelle lotte pio tutti a
schiaffi vederla in qua trovato la r la
r la missione bravissimi ma se si esce
mi siete scemi in realtà ragazzi nella
nostra squadra c'è anche sto tizio che
non si sa chi cazzo sia perché esso
gioco le squadre sono fatte da cinque
persone noi siamo in quattro quindi
hanno aggiunto un tizio a carissimo la
nostra squadra che ogni tanto durante la
partita proverà a parlare con noi in
inglese tipo adesso perché se vuoi nel
mac o gli assenti quei grassi è vero
l'ha detto sul serio un problema loro
successo
stai bene come la tolga un medico che
siete tutti a petto nudo ma che cazzo
siete dei veri crombie porca fa caldo fa
caldo ma basta funzione essenziale cioè
ecco la guarda da farsi vi prego c'è
invitiamo la casa c'è quest'uomo è una
leggenda mondo davanti sia dietro bolina
naso nel concorso bene siamo tipo ma gli
alberi cene scontati dietro gli alberi
quando avete tutti un albero a portata
di albero di terreno che ci si mette
tutti dietro la juve va bene 21 mettete
subito 49 dovevo continuare a seguirlo
perché poi si accorge che non ci sono
più e che ci rispetta il 6 girando sta
guardando perché io sono la juve vai vai
nasconditi web sono riuscite fermi lo
ripete che figo abbiamo la marazzina
fighissimo e che sta guidando award il
più perfetto c'è una pistola un kit va
bene dai
porca [ __ ] mi son parliamo gli occhi
verdi o non so io ho chiesto il casco ce
l'ho io no dai
porca [ __ ] mi stai dando veramente
alberti maledizioni veli guido io la
macchina che so guidare che cita le
patenti io video io ho sete tranquilli
venite tutti e chi è quello che manca
non importa noi andiamo via andiamo
ragazzi ma che cazzo mai
veniamo regalano subito dai
usate in tre dietro guardate che dopo
più di tre persone non posso portare che
poi mi fanno la multa è cazzi vostri
ragazzi quando si guida sempre quando
alla strada e la prima volta nella mia
vita che porta qualcuno in macchina non
ho mai fatto una fine gta mi sento di
poter fare cose belle tipo questo sì
bravo se non abbracciando ad un
villaggio cosa facciamo ci fermiamo ci
fermiamo a costo a destra ripreso il
parcheggio c'è anche un ecco
parcheggiato usciamo
c'è un peccato qua ci dividiamo mi sa
che quindi possibile passo io passito
bastardo oggi una macchina cinema piace
il tipo che ha un'altra macchina ne
abbiamo qua in abbiano trento tale
fruttato sappiamo guidare di oncino lo
uccido mi dispiace non sei mai stato mio
amico perché ti ho sempre odiato sin dai
tempi dell'asilo
scattano le cose ignorantissimo sul
layout e neve di legare troppo studio
festival tutte forse riusciamo a
ribaltare cosa succede ma perché
aspettatemi inca siete tutti
l'informazione allora se stanno karate
che ci sia il col parlamento c'è il
bombardamento scarano e una squadra o ne
vedo uno spetta l'ho preso cazzo non lo
uccide un peccato il cecchino beccato
cecchino e sulla terra dove il soggetto
della prima casa però non è morto cazzo
coprite infatti qualcosa ce non sparate
anche voi sono mica sono tutti contro di
me and you tool un giocatore ma non ce
l'ho colpito non ho fatto niente perché
chi perché vende sente bene e non ne ho
di più
26 al cazzo e come vedo c'è un po della
grande successo del cazzo meno al 100
per prendere loro i nostri valori sono
dentro una casa però maledizione pieno
di gente
1 giu poi attraverso poi doveva essere
sono giù dalle scale io mi sparano
l'oceano e sparando sono uscito eccoti
ti vedo i miei money money money money
aspetta che c'è alla finestra c'è la
finestra
si riesca non c'è odio lei sono caduti
in mano tantissimo però c'è la chance
ancora salvi non sono crollati vai vai
vai bye bye bye bye bye bye registrati
gli ho coperto e roberto voglio un
grandissimo nicchia che operazione di
salvataggio assurda grande educati ad
hoc
ripercorrete passari prendermi perché
c'è quello che sta tenendo sotto tiro
dove devo andare dove vado ray su per la
montagna per l'attore un attimo è un
attimo siamo sulla torre radio cosa
facciamo questo congelamento cca
integratore ragazzo diverso vale
affanculo so provato a uccidere la vita
ci ho provato esso cadendo cic ha avuto
la bt idea geniale di andare alla torre
a radio persone uccise 0 veicoli
distrutti 1 perfetta da chio ragazzi
abbiamo fatto cagare non che ci si
aspettasse di meglio magari la prossima
volta cerchiamo di fare una roba un po
più decente ci siamo ammazzati a vicenda
l'altro poco mente ragazzi spero che
video vi sia piaciuto e cosa sai dice
vito è piaciuto affatto un momento è un
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook e
come vidotto prescrizione se la serie si
discute ci vediamo proseguito ragazzi